[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID LEVIN: OK, today
I'm pleased to introduce
Jon Morris.
Jon is the first author that
that has us do a finger pop,
so he has that honor, for sure.
[LAUGHTER]
He's also been writing humor
and culture-related content
for more than a decade.
His long-running blog
on failed, ignored,
or just plain weird comic
books gone and forgotten
contains more than 800 entries
on the abandoned and dusty
corners of the comic book biz.
Not only did Jon score an
appearance on This American
Life to discuss what
makes a superhero fail
to catch the
popular imagination,
but it also provided the
foundation for his first book,
The League of Regrettable
Superheroes, published
by Quirk Books of Philadelphia.
And that led to
the book he's here
to discuss today, The Legion
of Regrettable Supervillains.
Please join me in giving
Jon a warm welcome.
JON MORRIS: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
That's good, I
like that applause.
My name is Jon Morris.
I'm the author of The Legion
of Regrettable Supervillain.
It's a collection
of more than 100
of the weirdest, the wildest,
and the most underrated
supervillains in
comic book history,
and is the successor
to the book The League
of Regrettable Superheroes
which did the same thing
for the good guys.
And as I mentioned,
I've been writing
the blog Gone and Forgotten
for 20 years this year.
It's an anniversary.
And all of that has served to
make me a walking encyclopedia
of weird comic book
knowledge, which
is a direct middle finger
to my college education.
[LAUGHTER]
Tough luck, mom and dad.
You scrimped and
saved for nothing.
This also is my second
visit to a Google campus.
I actually visited the
Mountain View Campus.
That's your corporate
headquarters, right?
Back, it's got to be about
eight, nine years ago.
And it is literally
the one place
I've been that looks most
like a supervillain's lair--
[LAUGHTER]
--complete with metal dinosaur.
And this part I swear is true--
I had two very lovely young
people guiding me around,
giving me a tour.
One of the things
they showed me was
a concert hall on the
campus with a lone piano.
One of the young
folks, unprompted--
we didn't ask her to do
this, nobody mentioned it,
sat down and started playing I
believe it's called the Toccata
in D Minor, it's that Phantom of
the Opera [VOCALIZING] music--
the most evil thing you can
play on a keyboard instrument.
[LAUGHTER]
Which does remind me,
if I'm not mistaken,
the corporate motto
of Google is--
don't be evil.
Do I have that correct?
All right.
And how many of you are evil?
[LAUGHTER]
[SIGHS] Hands, fair enough.
Now the thing, is in the
booming tech industry,
I think it's a mistake
to cut yourself off
from a potential new
kind of technology,
or a new realm of business.
So if Google does ever
consider going evil,
I have some potential
tech startups for it
that might be positive
avenues for them.
So we're going to Shark
Tank a few of them today.
I'm going to bring you
five great tech start--
I'm sorry, I mean
five great evil--
[LAUGHTER]
--tech startup opportunities.
Take notes.
And if you're in the
corporate department,
my finder's fee is 20%.
Number one, prosthetics.
The prosthetics
industry in America
is increasing exponentially.
And that fact is terrifying.
Sales of prosthetic arms have
gone up like 300% this year.
And why, and who do we blame,
and how do we stop that?
But in the meantime, it's
still a growing industry.
And if you're going to look
for your supervillain who
is most likely to give
you the in on prosthetics,
we're going to go back
80 years to vicious Nazi
super-criminal-- and
I promise I will often
make you look at the technology
of vicious Nazi super
criminals, but we're going
to look at The Crane.
Now, you might
ask yourself, what
does the character called The
Crane use for prosthetics?
Wings?
A beak?
Knees that bend backwards?
Nope.
Extending telescoping arms.
[LAUGHTER]
And I know some of you
might be interested, or work
on prosthetics, and
you are concentrating
on haptics and neurofeedback
and instantaneous response.
None of you thought about
what it takes to reach stuff
on the top shelf.
[LAUGHTER]
This is the one
supervillain who's
power is, he never has to ask
an associate for assistance.
He can just get his little
mini fridge for his dorm,
check out, walk
right out of Walmart.
To give more credit
to The Crane--
and again, I'm not going to
push too much Nazi technology
on you, but he has
a second invention
to his credit, the
Nazi-saurus Rex.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a metal dinosaur
beholden to the Nazi cause,
and is a robot
driven by The Crane.
The most wonderful thing
about comic books, by the way,
is, this is an image of a
robot t-rex with a Nazi garter
fighting a naked stone giant
in the middle of the ocean,
and the giant has a tiny
teenage King on his shoulder,
and a man with telescoping arms
are in the head of a dinosaur,
and I don't feel like
I need to explain this.
[LAUGHTER]
There's no context that
will make it better.
[LAUGHTER]
That's great.
As a runner-up to the
prosthetics industry,
I do want to point out another
character, the Mr. Pointer, who
kills with the
power of rudeness.
[LAUGHTER]
Your mom told you
not to do this.
Mr. Pointer's hand is fake--
or, it exists, but it's not
a hand as we think of it.
It's hollow, and
it contains a gun.
But it's a special gun.
It's a gun that shoots
frozen slivers of poison
at the speed of a bullet.
This is a dangerous
man to dapper with.
Well, that didn't work
as well as I was hoping.
Fair enough.
Second field-- wearables.
This is a huge technological
opportunity these days.
You've got your Fitbit,
you have your watches,
you have your Google
Glasses-- three pieces
of technology I don't own.
But if I did own them,
I would very much
want them to be
what The Dude wears.
The Dude is the best-dressed
villain in comic.
In fact, he's dressed to kill.
That's such a good joke,
they put it right there.
[LAUGHTER]
Just as an aside,
The Dude's nemeses
were Bullet Man and Bullet Girl.
These were police scientists
who invented a metal
they fashioned into a helmet
that allowed them to fly,
and was hyper magnetic, and
so it attracted bullets.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a short
lived use, at best.
The Dude had--
for instance, here
he's got a hat with
a razor sharp brim.
He's got a cigarette holder
that can shoot darts or gas,
and he's got a cravat, which
is just a really nice cravat.
And the diamond pin explodes.
A couple of the
things he does do,
he has a boutonniere that shoots
burning, corrosive acid gas,
and cuff links that
shoot poison darts.
It's always a big day
in a young man's life
when his father gives him his
first pair of murderous dart
cufflinks.
Another field you may have
some interest in, adhesives.
I know that's a little
out of Google's range,
but you can't let 3M have
a throttle on that forever.
Now, in the world of
superheroes, who knows more
about adhesives than your
friendly neighborhood wall
crawling amazing
spectacular Spider-Man?
Who knows more?
Spider Man.
[LAUGHTER]
20 years before Peter
Parker walked face first
into an angry
radioactive spider,
Captain Marvel was
facing this fella.
His-- I'll walk over
here to point it out.
He tells us that he has
invented an invention which
squirts out plastic, which
hardens into a sticky thread
when it meets the air.
And he learned this by
watching spiders at work.
Point of order, spiders
know nothing of plastics.
[LAUGHTER]
Also, if you ever do
give up, don't be evil.
I weave my webs of
crime everywhere
is a super good motto.
[LAUGHTER]
The delivery vector that Spider
Man uses to fire off his goop
lacks a little finesse.
It appears to be a pillow with
a fire hose attached to it--
[LAUGHTER]
--or a crippled bagpipe.
The most alarming thing
about this sequence
is that we learn
in a single panel
that Captain Marvel has
had taffy all over his face
at some point in his life.
[LAUGHTER]
Also, just a point, some
of you aren't that clever.
I know what that
looks like, too.
Looks like the top searched
category on Pornhub.
Ooh, that one didn't
go over well either.
[LAUGHTER]
We're all a little embarrassed
about the category search.
Not a problem, I'll remember it.
Number four, the
internet of things.
This has always been a
huge focus of technology.
We want every appliance and
every piece of furniture
to be interconnected so that our
refrigerators can send nudes.
But nobody does it--
there was si-- just
for the record, silent laughter.
There was so much
silent laughter.
[LAUGHTER]
That one worked.
But your inner connectivity will
never top that of Lord Lazee,
or as I like to call
him, Lord Lay Z,
Like Jay Z, because
he's got 99 buttons.
[LAUGHTER]
He also looks real familiar.
I think I see that guy in
the mirror every morning when
I shave.
Still, Lord Lazee has
a fiendish recliner
with a sort of, frankly,
children's attachable tray full
of buttons and devices.
And he can do amazing
things with these devices.
He can send warships out over
the capitals of the world.
He can steal satellites.
He can shoot lasers.
And, if there's something that
requires the personal touch,
he can send his robot
double into effect.
Now, I may not have the
confidence of Lord Lazee,
but if I had a robot double,
I'd make him thinner.
[LAUGHTER]
A little bit.
To give Lord Lazee
a lot of credit,
he's one of the
few supervillains
who, in the course of
fighting his foe, wins.
This is him destroying
the Washington
Monument, and the
hero, utterly helpless
to do anything about it.
Go Lord Lazee.
However, Lord Lazee has
a rack full of buttons.
There is another villain who
can get it all done with one,
and that's Bloor--
[LAUGHTER]
--Dictator of Uranus.
I want to plead with you--
if ever the word Uranus
is not funny to you,
stop laughing at everything.
They're sending a
probe to Uranus.
You can see Uranus
through this telescope.
(WHISPERING) It's always funny.
What can Bloor do with
his single button?
Well, let's walk through it.
He can sound powerful
sirens, he can
launch entire fleets of rocket
ships to conquer other worlds,
he can make two
huge robots appear,
and apparently one
not-so-huge robot.
[LAUGHTER]
If the caption had
been bigger, it
would have been-- two
huge robots and one
of the two huge robot's cousin.
He came along.
We didn't ask.
[LAUGHTER]
But most importantly, he can
summon an Amazon regiment
of fighting women.
Amazon is really reaching.
That's one of the many
things you can order
with a push of a single button.
And lastly, doomsday weapons.
This is an untested field.
It's a great opportunity
for Google to blaze a trail.
What kind of doomsday weapons?
Well, here's Dr. Dracula,
part of a crew of,
and we'll quote here,
vampires as large as men.
[LAUGHTER]
Not sure how tall they normally
are, to be perfectly frank.
Dr. Dracula doesn't
invent anything,
but he does steal a death ray
from an American scientist.
A death ray that
is hell on mice.
And for that matter, if you've
ever heard that smoking kills,
it sure does if you're in
the path of the death ray.
Also armed with some
beautiful death weapons
is Mr. Hydro, the
man made of spit.
He's gross.
He is a fellow capable of
turning himself into water,
and he has a habit of
escaping down toilets,
sinks, and drains.
So my guess is, he smells like
laundry you forgot to take out
of the wash for two days.
He again, steals his inventions,
created by this young fella
here.
This includes a death ray
pistol, a disintegrator,
and a gold-maker machine.
But luckily, he
locks it in a vault--
a vault with a huge
crack on the ceiling
that you can slip through
if you can turn to water.
Nice job.
And lastly, probably the best
known inventor of a doomsday
weapon, Lepus the Fiend.
This is a creation
of Fletcher Hanks,
a creator that you should look
up because he's bugnuts insane.
[LAUGHTER]
I shall destroy all
the civilized planets.
How is he going to destroy
all the civilized planets?
With a ray.
That's how I'd do it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that is your list
of potential new markets
for Google to enter.
Again, 20% finder's fee.
Contact me after
the show, I have
most of these guys' numbers.
Thank you very much.
DAVID LEVIN: This
book is a second
in a series of books
about superheroes.
And how did you start
writing these books?
JON MORRIS: Well at this
point, it's momentum.
I've been writing about these
weird characters since 1997.
And a lot of--
actually, weirdly,
a lot of the characters in the
book do come from the blog,
but I was able to
find dozens more
that I had never
even, to be honest,
heard of before I started
doing the research.
DAVID LEVIN: Also, like
I mentioned in the intro,
it sounds like
after the blog you
went on This American Life, and
then Quirk Books, and so on.
In your episode of This American
Life, you had something where--
there's another piece in
there where John Hodgman ask
people about whether they'd
rather the power of visibility
or flight.
In that sphere,
could you give us
two regrettable
superhero/villain powers
to choose between?
JON MORRIS: I very
much will, but I really
want to ask everybody
in the crowd.
So the question is-- this
is John Hodgman before he
was famous, asking
if you could have
either invisibility or
the power of flight,
which would you choose?
How many people would
want invisibility?
And the power of flight?
How many people want the
power of invisibility
so they can steal things?
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
How many people want
the power of flight
so they can save money
on airplane tickets?
[LAUGHTER]
We're simple creatures.
There are a couple
I really like.
I'm very fond of
Batroc Ze Lepair
who is a French supervillain.
Actually made it into one
of the Captain American
movies, bless his heart.
He's a master of
savate, which is
a French foot-fighting style.
And he leaps like a frog, which
is where his name comes from.
Of course, it's Batroc
as in batrachian.
And I very fond of not just his
acrobatics-- because obviously
I'm not doing
cartwheels every day,
but I really love his
giant handlebar mustache,
and the fact that he speaks with
Marie Chevalier accent, which
I can never (FRENCH ACCENT)
personally master, myself.
Oh, and then otherwise, Swarm.
Comics are filled with people
either made of or themed
about bees.
Swarm is--and do you mind if
I tell a little story about
Swarm?
DAVID LEVIN: Please.
JON MORRIS: Want to
tell you about Swarm
because he has the
most avoidable origin
in the history of comic books.
[LAUGHTER]
Swarm is formerly a
Nazi horticulturalist
who escapes Germany
at the end of the war,
goes to South America.
One night he sees a meteor
fly over his property.
He goes and hunts it down.
He finds that it's crashed
next to a hive of killer bees,
but the radiations
from the meteor
have made them docile,
easy to command, and twice
their normal size.
Now, he is a Nazi hoping to
reinvigorate the 4th Reich
and take over the world,
and he has in front of him
a meteor that makes
its victims twice
their size, but
completely docile,
and some fat bees
who want to sleep.
[LAUGHTER]
And he thinks, (GERMAN ACCENT)
I'm going to take the bees.
[LAUGHTER]
And so he takes the bees
back to his laboratory,
and the first thing
he wants to do
is teach them to kill
again, which they do--
him.
[LAUGHTER]
And if they actually flense
the flesh from his body--
because these are
industrious bees.
And then they take
over his body,
and then he is a
man made of bees--
or I prefer to call, a
man made of Nazi bees.
Now, I could very happily
be made of democratic bees.
I would much prefer that.
But being made of bees seems
to have some advantages.
If you can name one, I'd
be appreciative, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--mostly it's cool.
AUDIENCE: Lots of honey.
JON MORRIS: Lots of honey.
DAVID LEVIN: So these
may be hard to summarize,
but I think frog legs,
or made of bees, right?
Which one would--
JON MORRIS: Frog--
DAVID LEVIN: Sorry, go ahead.
JON MORRIS: Uh, bees.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah.
Bees?
Made of bees?
JON MORRIS: I was actually
fooling when I took a moment
to think about it.
[LAUGHTER]
Because the answer
is bees, every time.
DAVID LEVIN: Made of bees.
JON MORRIS: My
favorite superhero
from the first book,
if I can zing off,
is a character
called the Red Bee.
This is a golden age character,
came out in the 1940s.
I'll tell you before I tell
you anything about him,
he was obviously
tongue-in-cheek.
The creators used
the pseudonym B. H.
Apiary for his stories,
the B. H. probably standing
for Bee Hive.
Still, the Red Bee was an
assistant district attorney
named Richard
Raleigh who was tired
of criminals
overrunning his city,
and taking advantage
of the justice system.
So he dressed up in a diaphanous
shirt, stripy leggings,
and went into battle with
a single bee named Michael
that lived in his belt buckle.
[LAUGHTER]
And when he was in
trouble, click, [BUZZES].
Now you might be asking,
what can a single bee
do against crime?
He can startle bad guys,
he can sting bad guys.
And one time when the
Red Bee was tied up
in a shack, Michael [BUZZES]
escapes, finds a razor blade
on a nearby table, brings
it back to the Red Bee
so he can cut himself free,
or, reflecting on his life,
maybe kill himself.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Makes sense.
We have an audience question.
JON MORRIS: Oh, hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it looks like a lot of
the material you look at
is from the golden
age or earlier.
Do you have-- who's
your most favorite
recent regrettable supervillain,
and superhero, actually?
I don't know if you still
read comics regularly.
JON MORRIS: I do.
You know, the number of comics
I have to read for the books,
and for Gone and Forgotten,
and another comic book
blog I write called the
Chronological Superman,
means I--
about 90% of my comic
reading is really
focused on the '40s
through the '60s.
It's usually-- there's always a
nice redux to some characters.
One of the characters in
the book is called MODOK.
This is a giant
head flying around
in what appears to be
a Japanese toilet--
[LAUGHTER]
--with his little arms
hanging out of the side.
And he was always a difficult
character to take seriously.
In recent years,
somebody realized, oh,
that's actually kind of funny.
And he's become more
of a comedic villain.
I really love that.
And then, this is
not a funny answer,
but there's a superhero
called the Vision.
I think he's actually been one
of the Captain America movies.
And he just got a great story
by a writer named Tom King.
And it's one of
the best superhero
comics I've ever read.
So now I couldn't think of a
regrettable one there, but--
oh, and Squirrel Girl who was
actually in the first book,
and is now the most popular
superhero at Marvel.
I'm going to take a little
credit for that, just a smidge.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Let's go for
another audience question,
since we have one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So when I look at
your cover here,
the one that stands out,
that inspires me the most
is the Horrible Hand.
JON MORRIS: Ah,
the Horrible Hand.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
if you could share with me
the story behind that one.
JON MORRIS: I would love
to share my horrible hand.
The Horrible Hand is a villain--
there's actually a factotum
of a former wizard,
and a foe of a character
called Ibis the Invincible.
Ibis had something
called the Ibis
Stick, which could make
anything come alive,
and it would obey him--
which is pretty good.
And the Horrible Hand
was a demon's hand
that was summoned by one of
Ibis' enemies to kill him.
And mostly what he can do is
do the poking, the pushing,
the choking--
the usual hand stuff.
So you probably could
have just gotten a dude.
[LAUGHTER]
The reason the Hand is in there,
besides the fact that it's
a good graphic and it
is a weird villain,
is that in the first book, there
was a character called the Eye,
was a giant, flaming,
disembodied eye
that would show up in people's
bedrooms or their living
rooms when they
weren't expecting it,
command them to fight evil,
and then pfft, disappear.
And I just thought
between the two of them,
that's a stupendous pairing--
the Eye and the Hand.
Although I think
the Eye probably
is going to come out the worst.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: It's
[INAUDIBLE] the cover, right?
I love the cover.
It feels very nostalgic to
me with the whole little bin
and all the white
dots, and all of this.
Remind me of old comics.
How did you come up
with these covers?
JON MORRIS: Well, I was
working in conjunction
with Tim O'Neill.
He's the designer
at Quirk Books.
Very young guy, just got
out of design school.
And Regrettable Superheroes
was the very first thing
he designed.
So I'm super proud of him.
And feel very blessed to have
him be the designer on my book.
I will say, I got to
contribute two things when
we were putting this together.
I said, can we make it look like
a really old, worn comic book?
And can we put a stripe there?
And I'll count that as a credit.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: But why the stripe?
JON MORRIS: On older comics--
so one of my obsessions
that I'll probably point out
is mastheads.
I really love the design on
old comic book mastheads.
And one of the things
they did for awhile,
each company has done stripes
in one capacity or another--
big Marvel and DC when I
say the companies, but also
the old golden agers.
Sometimes you just
put that stripe
because, when you're
looking at a rack of comics,
you really only see about
that much of the comic
because all that's
below the cover.
And then if you've got a
bunch of comics on the rack,
sometimes you only see
this much of the cover.
So companies used to put little
pictures of the characters
there.
They would put the title there.
Sometimes they would
just put a colored strip.
There was a company
called Red Band,
and Red Band always had
their red band on there
so you could always pick
them out of the crowd.
I always liked those.
DAVID LEVIN: Cool.
Another audience.
AUDIENCE: So a question
more meta about the book.
You've been writing this
blog for 20 years now,
and you really
kind of carved out
a niche of this subject matter
expert of an unusual subject
area.
JON MORRIS: I like to think so.
AUDIENCE: So just
for other people
kind of interested in
pursuing oddball passions
and fixations and things like
that to their logical extremes,
could you talk a
little bit about how
you got into this
in the first place,
and how you've carried it
through all these years?
JON MORRIS: I will
say, the number one
technique for carrying it
all the way through 20 years
is, periodically say you're
going to take a month off,
and stretch that
out to three years.
[LAUGHTER]
Bless Gone and Forgotten.
I've always enjoyed doing
it, but sometimes life
gets in the way a little bit.
And I have, probably
out of the 20 years,
taken about seven years off.
But still, it helps to
have a crew of folks
to test yourself against,
because you will always
find other people
with weird obsessions.
Andrew Otis Weiss,
Matt Maxwell--
I blanked on his
name, and Chris Sims
over at ComicsAlliance
also always do these kind
of weird comic book things.
And it's really great
to bounce off of them.
Also, if you can get an
enemy in the field, that
is hugely helpful because you
look at what they do, and then
sometimes you're
like, hmm, I can
be funnier about that
very same book, bop.
And you just try to
bury them a little.
[LAUGHTER]
Not the friendliest advice,
but it's really good advice.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Another
audience question.
AUDIENCE: In the recent
Lego Batman movie,
there was throwaway joke about
all the bad Batman villains
that have come out in the past.
Do you feel like
you've influenced this?
Have they contacted
you and asked, hey,
can you come up with a
list of weird supervillains
we used to have?
JON MORRIS: I think there's been
a real turn towards enjoying
the goofier villains
because we have
been kind of darker and darker.
When Tim Burton did Batman--
or actually, when Tim
Burton did Batman,
and when Richard
Donner did Superman,
their villains, played by big
celebrities, were kind of fun,
still.
There was something
kind of wacky and weird.
Even Batman Returns, which
has Danny DeVito turning
in a amazing, creepy,
gross performance.
It's still kind of funny
and over-the-top and campy.
But what other TV and movie
producers took from that
is trying to make it darker
and darker, and grimmer
and grimmer.
And I think this
is just backlash.
I think we now like the idea
of really goofy supervillains
because you can only take
really grim stuff for so long
before you want to
see something that
makes you laugh a little bit.
DAVID LEVIN: When I first hear
the term regrettable here,
it just sounds like
something that somebody
wishes they hadn't done.
That isn't quite the meaning,
I think, you meant for this.
What do you mean by
Regrettable Supervillains?
JON MORRIS: Almost everybody
in here, I like to think,
had the potential to
become something great.
And actually, a few of
the characters in the book
are still used, and
are still popular.
Batroc, MODOK, a couple
characters I mentioned still
show up in the comics.
I think there's a
good chance MODOK's
going to be in an upcoming Iron
Man or Captain America movie.
But for the most part,
some vaguery of the market,
or a failing publisher,
or just being
buried in the back of
an anthology title kept
a lot of these characters from
reaching any kind of potential,
or reaching the big audience.
And then there are some
that are genuinely awful.
[LAUGHTER]
But they are the
minority in the book.
I always try to find something
that celebrates about them,
because I'd like
to see all of them,
in one fashion or
another, come back.
DAVID LEVIN: Oh.
So you mentioned some
that are genuinely awful.
Which-- could you name
a few of those for fun?
JON MORRIS: So
comics, of course,
are influenced by the current
events, and about our culture.
And we were at war.
I guess we are at
war, but we were
at war with Germany and
Japan back in the '40s.
So you got a lot of Japanese
villains who were awful,
just terrible
racial caricatures.
And then during the Red Scare,
a lot of Chinese supervillains
who were equally awful.
And there is one
called Egg Fu, who
is a 40 foot tall egg with
a giant prehensile Mandarin
mustache, who could use it
to-- he beats up Wonder Woman.
He actually kills Wonder
Woman in this story.
But it's a comic book,
so [SNAPS] she's back.
And he was one of those
things where he would
reverse his Rs and his Ls.
And he had buck teeth,
and he had yellow skin.
And it was a grotesque
thing to look at.
And the problem with them is,
they keep trying to have--
well, the second problem is--
[LAUGHTER]
--they keep trying
to bring him back
in some fashion or another.
He was brought back
in the '90s, and it
was meant to be like, let's
be ironic about the racism.
Not that good.
And then a very good
writer named Grant Morrison
brought him back.
Didn't call him Egg Fu, made him
an egg-shaped weird scientist
from another planet.
And it worked until
someone called him Egg Fu,
and then all of the
associations come flooding back.
So kind of wouldn't-- if Egg
Fu disappeared from the planet
tomorrow, it wouldn't be bad.
Nobody would suffer.
DAVID LEVIN: Some
villains probably
made it, even though they had
the chance to be regrettable.
Which ones do you think slid
through that little thin line
there, whatever you
want to call it?
JON MORRIS: I
might make enemies.
DAVID LEVIN: If it's too
sensitive, we can skip that.
JON MORRIS: As a really
big Superman fan,
I think I was prejudiced against
putting any of his villains
in, even though a lot of
them are major goofballs.
His most important-- one of
his most popular villains
who, his entire run, is
a character Mr. Mxyzptlk
from the fifth
dimensional land of Zrfff.
And he's a funny
little man in a derby,
and he's got magic powers.
And I love him and I think
he's a great character,
but he is-- he looks ridiculous
next to the most powerful
mortal being in the universe.
And he still wins,
which is great.
There's a character called
the Prankster, who's
a pencil-necked, pumpkin-bodied
guy who pulls pranks, scams,
and cons, and he always
gets the best of Superman.
And I'll tell you this one--
he's the first villain to
knock Superman unconscious.
And here's how he did it--
he frustrated Superman,
got under his skin.
He irritated him so much that,
against his better judgment,
Superman hauled off and threw
a legitimate super punch
at the Prankster's head, a
shot that would have killed him
if the Prankster hadn't ducked.
And Superman's fist goes
all the way around and--
[LAUGHTER]
--knocks him out flat.
And there's also Terra-Man,
who was a space cowboy.
And he had weapons like
radioactive tumbleweeds,
or he had a tobacco
pouch that was a grenade,
and he flew on a Pegasus.
And I-- oh, and he's based
off of Clint Eastwood,
and I kind of love him.
So, couldn't put him in.
But yeah, he's made it.
DAVID LEVIN: And there
were a few villains that,
as a parent I couldn't-- as a
parent of a teenager I did kind
of relate to.
There was Tino the Terrible
Teen, Sinestro, Boy Fiend.
JON MORRIS: Boy Fiend?
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah,
boyfriend, boy fiend,
what's the difference?
JON MORRIS: Yeah.
If you've got a
teenage daughter,
they're all boy fiends, right?
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah.
JON MORRIS: Comics,
of course, are
really reflexive of culture,
and whatever seems to be scary
and menacing becomes a villain.
And you have to
keep in mind, these
were all being written and drawn
by men in their 40s and 50s.
And they must have looked at
the Beatles scene and the mods,
and just went, oh, these kids--
and actually made
villains out of teenagers,
which is sort of
the opposite of what
you want to do for your market.
[LAUGHTER]
Teenagers love being
told they're monsters.
So yeah, Tino or
the Terrible Teen
was the biggest rock star
in the world who ended up
hating the Challengers
of the Unknown
because secretly his brother was
a member of the Challengers who
was murdered.
And so he used his powerful
empire of rock music
to attack the Challengers
of the Unknown, which
is the perfect thing
that a 50-year-old thinks
a young kid would use
as weapon, is like, oh,
they got that rap music,
and they're on my lawn.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Well--
JON MORRIS: Is that it?
DAVID LEVIN: That's about it.
Thank you very much for coming.
JON MORRIS: You have a question?
What?
DAVID LEVIN: Oh, sorry,
one other question.
You can say it, we'll
repeat it up here.
AUDIENCE: What you say is
probably your favorite villain?
Since you always look at it,
what makes a bad villain.
What makes a really
good villain?
DAVID LEVIN: I'll repeat
it for the recording,
but what's your
favorite villain?
JON MORRIS: So I'm
a big fan of anyone
who gets a little morally
ambiguous because villainy
is great, and it's
wonderful to have
a big, over-the-top, campy
arch, even Grand Guignol
kind of like exciting villain.
But it's great when they
get into a villain's head
a little bit.
Lex Luthor started off his--
first 25 years of his existence
is just Luthor the evil
scientist, the war profiteer.
In 19-- I think it's 1959,
and I should know this
because I just wrote about
it, he gets a backstory.
And it turns out he and
Superman were friends
when they were teenagers.
And it was an
accident that Superboy
caused that made him
lose his hair and turn
evil, which happens.
[LAUGHTER]
And then this became
a story, really,
about the potential of
this young boy genius,
and how it was wasted on
this meaningless feud,
and for his ego,
and how it really
destroyed what could
potentially have been
someone who saved the world.
That's a really good background.
There's also a character named
Bullseye who fights Daredevil
very often.
And he started off as just--
like all supervillains
do, he's got a costume
and a gimmick and a name.
But the more they
interacted, the more we
learned about Bullseye
has mental illnesses,
and Bullseye has
hallucinations, and Bullseye
had a promising career, but
he just has these commands
and voices, and sees things,
and he has to listen to them.
And it made him more
sympathetic while making
him a lot more terrifying,
because the fear of losing
control is always a
big fear for everybody.
There's a couple.
DAVID LEVIN: Just waiting to
see if anybody else stands
up quickly.
Looks like we have one more.
JON MORRIS: We got one more.
No respect for chairs.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I'll admit that
I have spent very, very little
time of reading comic books--
AUDIENCE: Boo.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know-- oh.
[LAUGHTER]
JON MORRIS: Get out.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
a lot about the culture,
but some of these just
seem very, very out there.
Is that-- are people going for
kind of these weird characters,
or is it a function of having
to come up with so many villains
that they just come out weird,
and sometimes fall flat?
JON MORRIS: That is it.
So a couple of things happen.
A lot of the
characters I discussed
today were all from the golden
age, and there were no rules.
They had just made up the genre.
So everything was possible,
nothing was forbidden.
That's how you get a flaming
hand that just pokes people out
of windows, because no one
says, that's a little goofy.
Run with it.
But yeah, we change our
attitudes every decade or so,
and the audiences want
something different.
I'm really shocked that
the Joker continues
to be a very popular
villain, because he
was very good for the '80s where
we were really into bloodshed,
and we wanted the villains
to be super bad and evil.
And he had a good comeback in
the 2000s right after September
11th because we were,
again, looking for really
objectively evil characters.
And I feel like
we're kind-- wel we
do have some objectively
evil characters we
have to deal with in real life.
But I feel like in fiction, we
should be a little beyond that.
But yeah, the other
thing you said
about having to make so many--
either of the big two
companies produces 60, 70, 80,
90 titles a month.
And if you're a writer,
you've got to crack through--
every third, fourth
issue, you've
got to have somebody new.
So they're just creating
them hand over fist.
There was a trend in
the 1960s and '70s--
because editors usually are the
people who flesh out the ideas,
and sometimes name
the characters,
there was a flood
of characters who
were clearly named after things
you'd just see on a desk.
[LAUGHTER]
There was the Eraser who
got mentioned before, there
was the Human Eraser, there's
Calender Man who was mentioned.
I'm sure there was a
paperclip somewhere.
Oh, there's something
called Paste Pot Pete.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Before-- it
even sounds like Spider-Man
was considered one of these
that was a throwaway character.
Stan Lee's publisher's
like, no way.
It's spiders,
people hate spiders.
It's a teenager, we can't
have teenagers at all.
JON MORRIS: Yeah, him
making Spider-Man a teenager
was a huge deal.
This was-- it's
not unprecedented.
There were teenage and
child heroes in the 1940s
and '50s, but making it a
teenager into whose head you
can go, and really see--
you know, Stan was channeling
his own teenage fears.
He was pretty young.
He'd been writing comics at 14
back in the golden age-- or 16.
But yeah, the story behind
all of Marvel Comics
falls down to a guy
named Martin Goodman, who
was the president of the
company, who would go golfing
with the guys who ran what
we know now as DC Comics.
And they were golfing one
day, and the president of DC
was just bragging, oh, this
comic book Justice League.
Oh, it's great, we
couldn't be selling more.
So Goodman went right
into the offices,
knocked on his nephew
Stan Lee's door
and says, give me a Justice
League, and walks out.
And then Stan creates
Fantastic Four,
and he creates
Spider-Man, and the Hulk,
and with the assistance of
course of Jack Kirby and Don
Heck and all these
other great creators,
and Steve Ditko of course--
and creates a phenomenon,
because basically Martin
Goodman had a bad day golfing.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID LEVIN: Another
audience question.
AUDIENCE: So there's
a lot of stories
in the golden age of [INAUDIBLE]
where the superheroes were not
very well-defined,
and they ended up
with changed powers,
or that sort of thing.
But I'm not aware
of any villains that
have had that drastic change.
Are you aware of any?
JON MORRIS: So there's a villain
called the Ultra Humanite,
which is a great name,
and he started off
as actually Superman's
first arguable supervillain.
Superman when he debuted
went about a year and a half
just fighting crooks
and finks and jerks.
The Ultra Humanite,
when he shows
as Superman's
physical opposite--
he's an old, wiry, creaky
dude, and he naturally
dies at the hands of one
of his own evil plots.
But he comes back
about a year later
because his assistants
have transported his brain
into the body of a young
Hollywood actress named Delores
Winters, which makes,
by the way, the Ultra
Humanite the first transgender
character in comics.
Pack that one away
for bar trivia night,
it might come in handy.
[LAUGHTER]
Frankly, the editorship
and the audience
were a little not sold,
because this was, again,
the 1940s, on a man's
brain in a woman's body.
So they transplanted him
to a more palatable body,
which is a giant, weird,
mutant monkey creature.
[LAUGHTER]
So his tremendous intellect
is still his power,
but now of course he
has the physical power
of a giant, weird monkey.
That's a real drastic version.
There are powers that
change periodically.
Poison Ivy, one of Batman's
foes is a really good example,
because when she debuted, she
was just a master of poison.
And so she would scratch
people and poke people.
She had the poison
lipstick gag which
is always in comics
because you've
got to have a way for
boys to kiss the girls.
But now she controls plants,
and she makes evil plants.
And now she can make
plants do her commands.
Because someone basically
just looked at that costume
and said, oh, it's got
to be a plant creature,
and just wrote it.
And nobody corrected him, and
pfft, now she controls plants.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
one of the things that
makes having a really focused
position on this easier
is having an enemy.
Is that-- I don't know if
they're actual enemies,
you probably don't
want to share stories,
but if it's a
frenemy relationship,
do you have any good
stories of competitions
you've done with people?
JON MORRIS: My closest
frenemy is Chris Sims
over ComicsAlliance,
which started
because he's been trying to get
one of these books published
for decades.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, tough luck, Chris.
But I don't have a
story about the rivalry.
I usually just-- I bust on
him a little on podcasts,
and he busts a little on me.
My favorite Chris
Sims story is, he's
in West Virginia
or North Carolina,
somewhere that I
don't know what states
look like in that
part of the country.
And despite that, I was
at an Aaron Brothers
buying some frames, and I heard
two of the clerks talking.
I heard one of them
say, I have an opinion
about the new Spider-Man
movie, but I'll keep it short,
I'm not Chris Sims, here.
Which is amazing to me
that people were just
dusting him that, as far I
was aware, never met him.
So that's one of my favorite--
he doesn't believe me,
but that's a true story.
And I want you to pass it
around, if you'd be so kind.
[LAUGHTER]
But there's another
one where there
was a-- it's a pretty famous
comic creator actually
whose work I really
appreciate and really liked.
When I was a kid,
I used to copy him.
And he started doing
a wacky comics thing.
And I was just chatting with him
about it, and his was monthly,
and mine was three times a week.
And I mentioned that,
and he got real angry.
And I can't remember what he
said, but it was really snide.
And I just decided next year
is dedicated to burying you.
I'm going to take
the nuclear option.
AUDIENCE: So on all the
examples I can think of,
the name on the top
of the comic book
is the hero not the villain.
And villains also tend to be
associated only with one hero.
They don't move
from place to place.
I'm wondering if you
know of any examples
where a villain has
managed to transcend that,
to become bigger
than just one hero,
or get their name on the top.
JON MORRIS: If you are
planning on seeing the Justice
League of America-- it's just
Justice League, isn't it?
Justice League movie.
Darkseid, the big
bad guy in that
was originally created just to
be part of this little enclosed
universe of characters created
by the great Jack Kirby.
And he kind of filtered out
into the Superman universe,
and then he filtered out into
the Justice League universe.
Now he's the big bad
guy for everybody.
Kingpin is another
character who--
you probably saw him
on the Netflix show.
He started off as
a Spider-Man foe,
and he kind of
transplanted over.
And I will mention, too,
there's a lot of villains
who get their own books.
In fact, in the '70s,
they were so popular,
still riding on the
Batman '66 wave,
that there was a book
called The Secret Society
of Super Villains that featured
25, 30 of these characters.
All, by the way, all
dressed in weird costumes,
all with explosive powers.
One of them was a giant monkey.
And they were still secret.
[LAUGHTER]
But the Joker's had
his own book, Catwoman,
Harley Quinn have
had their own books.
Kingpin just got a title,
Lex Luthor has had a book.
They get their props and
dues every now and again.
DAVID LEVIN: So last question.
JON MORRIS: Oh, boy.
AUDIENCE: OK.
You mentioned MODOK as an
example of a supervillain who
was originally
supposed to be serious,
but then they realized he
was silly and made him silly.
Are the-- can you think of any
examples of a supervillain who
started out being
silly, but then they
decided that he was actually
more serious than intended?
JON MORRIS: Sure.
That is the story of the 1980s--
[LAUGHTER]
--particularly in DC Comics.
They had an event called the
Crisis on Infinite Earths.
It was their 50th anniversary.
They created a huge,
complicated continuity
with multiple universes
and multiple versions
of single heroes.
And it was incredibly
confusing to everyone
who didn't grow up reading
them since they were five.
So they simplified and
streamlined everything.
And that involved making
a lot of the villains
much more terrible.
Mr. Mxyzptlk I
mentioned earlier,
who's a funny little imp who
torments Superman with magic,
actually after being tricked out
of the universe the first time,
comes back furious that he's
been tricked-- because that
wasn't playing the
game right, and he
becomes a legitimate menace.
I'm blanking on one that
was a really good example,
so you tell me--
oh, no, that's OK.
The Penguin again, started
off in a little tuxedo.
After 1987, after the
crisis, he comes back
as a dude with filed down
teeth, and he's a cannibal.
That's unnecessary.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm OK with a tuxedo--
again, that was
probably inspired
by Danny DeVito's performance.
But yeah, they did amp them up
and make them a lot more evil.
And there is a comic
called Whatever Happened
to the Man of Tomorrow?
written by Alan Moore.
And it's supposed to be
the final Superman story.
And it brings back
all of his villains.
And there's a pretty
famous line from it,
after one of his oldest
friends is killed by two
of his silliest villains.
And it's-- when the menaces
come back as murderers,
what are the murderers
going to come back as?
Which, not just a
chilling line, but really
an excoriating statement
for what comics
had become by the late '80s.
DAVID LEVIN: Well,
thank you very
much for coming and joining us.
JON MORRIS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]